c'est aussi ce matin en savoir un peu
plus sur l'a10 pour tous ceux qui
souhaiteraient pourquoi pas monter leurs
activités qui n'ont pas forcément les
moyens
ça a été votre qu'un jaune à héros
puisqu'il ya encore très peu de temps
vous étiez au rsa je suis toujours vous
êtes toujours ça oui pour combien de
temps je ne sais pas encore
tout dépendra de comment ça évolue en
fait au niveau de la friperie raconter
quand votre aventure johanna héros parce
que on peut se poser plein de questions
on se dit comment quand on est au rsa on
arrive à ouvrir une friperie parce que
c'est ce que vous possédez aujourd'hui à
dijon s'est ouvert depuis décembre donc
ça existe depuis quelques mois oui c'est
un projet que j'avais déjà depuis
plusieurs années et je vous ai pas trop
me lancer je cherchais vraiment à
conceptualiser en projet et ne pas juste
ouvrir un magasin de vêtements
donc c'est un projet qui date d'il ya
six ou sept ans en arrière et je me suis
lancée en allant d'abord voir la cci
c'est le genre de commerce voilà c'est
ça pour avoir la plagne mans qui n'a pas
pu se faire
j'ai ensuite été voir bg&e perspective
donc
ce sont des conseillers à la création et
à la reprise d'entreprise donc j'ai
effectué une formation pendant trois
mois dans leurs locaux et ensuite je me
suis mis à chercher un local déjà et on
a parlé de l'adie vu que je n'avais pas
accès aux prêts bancaires
j'ai donc diminuer mes besoins initiaux
par trois pour pouvoir rentrer dans les
cases et pouvoir bénéficier du
microcrédit par l'adie jona héros vous a
parlé de la vie vous avez donc toqués
auprès de sébastien morel et de ses
confrères comment ça s'est passé
explique et moi j'ai eu d'abord un
premier rendez vous
avec un conseiller et j'avais déjà
préparé tout mon business plan en fait
comme pour présenter devant les banques
et ensuite c'est passé en commission
donc ça a été très rapide dans deux
trois semaines s'est passé en commission
et ensuite il ya eu le décaissement du
crédit le crédit de combien de dix mille
euros que vous rembourserai lorsque
genre définition s'est dit voilà c'est
ça qu'est je rentre bien combien ça
parce que voilà pas forcément mais l'a
dit c'est pas un puits sans fond on est
bien d'accord cette fois la rembourser
oui bien sûr la dir ont fait un film on
apporte une solution de financement est
également du conseil pour pouvoir
permettre si on prend l'exemple de
johanna joinel a rencontré le 25 octobre
elle a pris rendez vous avec geoffrey
qui a étudié sa demande de financement
il lui donne rendez vous et le neuf le 9
novembre ont signé le contrat de prêt
voilà on est sur des des process qui
sont rapides mais qui sont aussi
adaptées aujourd'hui à la nouvelle
manière de consommer d'entreprendre et
notre choix ou au niveau de la dit c'est
vraiment de pouvoir amener la solution
la plus efficace possible
la mieux adaptée par rapport aux besoins
de la personne qu'on rencontre donc dans
le cas de johanna baï avait besoin de
financer des investissements
il y avait besoin aussi d'amener de la
trésorerie pour lui permettre de se
développer
et puis après bah si c'est une histoire
de personnes de confiance
on rentre dans la vie des gens quand on
instruit me demande ça va de soi parce
qu'on fait un point sur l'analyse du
budget mais derrière ce qui nous
intéresse à partir du moment où on met
en place un financement au niveau de la
dce et est ce qu'on apporte une solution
une plus value à la personne pour lui
permettre de rebondir ou pas si on juge
qu' effectivement le financement de la
diva permettre à la personne de créer
son propre emploi de pouvoir développer
son activité est de rebondir être sortir
ce qu'on espère pour un johanna très
rapidement de du rsa ça sera une
réussite collective
il réussit d'abord pour johanna parce
qu'on aura réussi à lui trouver une
solution et puis à lui dire oui pour lui
permettre de se développer une réussite
pour tous
on va revenir sur des questions très
concrètes savoir si oui ou non vous
financer par exemple tous les types
d'activités parce qu'on peut se poser la
question c'est une friperie des six mois
demain
j'ai envie d'ouvrir une sandwicherie
autre chose on va envahir répondre à
cette question mais auparavant on va
revenir sur l'a10 l'association pour le
droit à l'initiative économique avec
cette immersion carrément avec ces deux
exemples en haute saône et dans le
territoire de belfort pas encore mieux
comprendre ce qu'elle a dit en bourgogne
franche comté regarder jessica ortigue
et travaille dans son jardin et dans des
conditions précaires assistantes de vie
auprès de personnes âgées
elle a dû se reconvertir après une chute
elle a fait de sa passion sa nouvelle
activité professionnelle elle a emprunté
deux fois 1000 euros auprès de l'adie
pour se lancer
ils m'ont croyait à un crédit et donc un
prêt d'honneur qui m'a aidé donc pour
pouvoir constituer mon stock en fait
et puis pour pouvoir avoir une petite
base pour démarrer correctement quoi
mais ne vous ont pas que donner de
l'argent
non effectivement on
on est très bon accompagnement donc
c'est vrai qu'ils sont très présents au
moindre souci on peut les appeler sont
toujours là pour nous aiguiller pour
nous conseiller
prochaine étape pour jessica ortigue et
trouver un atelier où une maison avec
une pièce qu'elle pourra consacrer à son
activité
[Musique]
jean-marc films l'un s'est installé dans
cette péniche propriété du grand belfort
il y a cinq ans lui en cuisine son
épouse dominique en salle depuis deux
salariés les ont rejoint cet été ça
s'est bien passé avec cette année a été
exceptionnelle je pense déjà à votre le
temps façon jamais cru qu'on préfère
autant qu il a emprunté à la 10 10 mille
euros la somme maximale pour acheter du
matériel et pour payer trois mois de
loyer en caution je suis allé à die
présenté mon projet c'est vrai que tout
de suite
il avait l'air emballé il n'y a pas les
mêmes relations entre la 10e' mois
contre une banque et moi moi je préfère
aider 2000 associations comme l'a dit
parce que voilà ça j'y crois parce que
c'est des gens typique qu'ils sont
humains
la banque elle est pas humaine et des
l'a dit oui car jean marc poulin à
reverser 5 % de son prêt soit 500 euros
à l'adie pour de futurs emprunteurs mais
tous les emprunteurs remboursent il
vraiment leurs prêts oui alors
heureusement sinon on n'existerait plus
depuis longtemps
on fait des financements adaptés c'est à
dire qu'on va travailler avec la
personne le projet donc on travaille le
besoin de financement par rapport aux 6
à sa situation personnelle à sa capacité
de remboursement
c'est pour ça qu'on arrive à récupérer
ben les fonds qu on fait emprunté est de
toute façon on est dans l'obligation de
les récupérer parce que nous mêmes nous
remboursons les banques ne nous prêtent
de l'argent selon l'adie les emprunteurs
sont souvent chômeurs et son diplôme et
trois ans après leurs prêts 84% d'entre
eux ont tonnes emploi pour vous jouer un
héros c'est bad kids une friperie a dit
jean ouverte grâce à l'adie y en a
beaucoup qui sont avec nous et qui se
disent tiens pourquoi pas moi beaucoup
en rêvent justement de monter leur
entreprise de créer ce que vous avez
fait vous par exemple quelque chose d'un
petit peu particulier mais passer du
rêve à la réalité c'est parfois un petit
peu compliqué qu est ce que vous dites à
ceux qui sont avec nous pour qu'ils
concrétisent leurs rêves faut se donner
les moyens
déjà il faut
aussi avoir les épaules je pense pour
ouvrir un commerce ou pour réaliser ses
rêves
et puis faut y croire c'est pas facile
tous les jours il faut y croire
il faut vraiment avoir cette énergie est
motivé il faut en vouloir
voilà faut rester motivé pouvait croire
aujourd'hui pour parler clair la
friterie est ouverte depuis décembre
on sait qu'il ya eu pas mal de
mouvements sociaux par ci par là et ça a
été compliqué dans l'économie vous vous
comptez en vivre très vite de votre
activité
j'espère j'espère oui un mot dégagé
rapidement un salaire pour le moment il
y avait tout ce qui se passe
actuellement
je ne ressens pas la baisse on va dire
du pouvoir d'achat des autres
commerçants ils sont installés depuis
peu plus longtemps que moi mais pour le
moment on va dire que j'arrive à faire
tourner le commerce
alors on a bien compris vous avez
bénéficié des êtres de la dîme est ce
que aujourd'hui maintenant que vous êtes
installé depuis quelques mois vous avez
encore justement c'était ce qui est
encore une ligne téléphonique est ce qu
il encore quelqu'un qui passe est ce que
vous avez encore des contacts avec les
dommages
j'ai des contacts oui si j'ai si j'ai
des besoins je peux envoyer un mail je
peux je peux l'appeler et c'est ils sont
vraiment très présent en fait si on a un
problème on peut on peut les contacter
et on n'attend pas une semaine ou deux
semaines pour avoir une réponse ça c'est
important sébaste et morale n'y a pas de
sav 1 vous vendez rien mais malgré tout
on peut quand même continuer à vivre à
l' aventure avec l'adie une fois qu'on a
signés bien sûr il ya les choses sont
complémentaires c'est à dire qu'on va
donner accès au capital et un
financement pour permettre aux personnes
soit créé souhaitent développer leurs
activités mais notre mission va pas
s'arrêter là on a on amène du conseil on
va amener du conseil sur des aspects
administratifs à des personnes des fois
qu'ils ont des difficultés avec la
langue avec l'écrit avec la
compréhension aussi de notre notre
écosystème administratif mais on peut
aussi intervenir et c'est surtout là
dessus qu'on intervient sur un volet
développement commercial vous financer
tous les types d'activités c'est la
serre morale parce que j'ai entendu dire
qu'aujourd'hui avait beaucoup beaucoup
de deux modes dans le massage dans
bien-être je me trompe pas alors tout ça
ça fait partie aujourd'hui effectivement
c'est une simple mode sur ce rapport
d'activité la haie
à partir du moment où l'activité légale
d'accord donc toutes les activités on a
vu un restaurant par exemple sur la
péniche avec l'exemple récemment dans la
nièvre une personne eric a créé un
atelier itinérant d'affûtage voilà qui
s'adresse aux agriculteurs ils
s'adressent à d'autres personnes qui
sont en situation très rural pour le
ramener à service rapide et des couteaux
étaient des faux à vous écouter ça va
c'est à moi que je me demande si vous
refusez des finalement vous acceptez
tout on n'accepte pas tout l'analyse on
va la porter sur plusieurs choses la
capacité de remboursement de la personne
donc sa situation financière aujourd'hui
le projet bien évidemment et c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure le le
sillon jugent eux que le financement va
permettre à la personne de se réinsérer
de rebondir on va proposer un
financement elle mettre en place si par
contre on jusque à l'état dans l'état
actuel des choses la situation est trop
complexe
on va plutôt proposer d'autres solutions
à la personne résoudre c'est peut-être
peut-être une partie de ses problèmes
financiers
pour pouvoir accéder dans un second
temps un financement de la di la moyenne
d'âge de ce que vous aidez tourne autour
de combien réponse rallier aux alentours
de 35 40 ans d'accord ok mais moi je
vais vous emmener à à pont de roide
vermondans c'est dans le doubs pour
faire la connaissance de matthews d'un
jeune artisan qui lui est au service de
la musique il a pas bénéficié des
services de la dîme est pas tout
l'artisanat c'est la première entreprise
de france vous aider aussi quelques
artisans n'ont pas envie d'envoyer un
petit clin d'oeil d'une semaine avant la
semaine de l'artisanat
on va revenir ensemble avant d'aller
retrouver amélie pu parler du printemps
saison des amours mais d'abord en contre
en ce jeune but est donc là on vient
vraiment presque cherchait déjà une note
très sûre sur les vibrations du bon on a
déjà quelque chose
à seulement 21 ans mathieu a ce don de
pouvoir dialoguer avec le bois le
modeler selon ses envies pour en faire
des guitares électriques sur mesure
tout part d'une simple planche d'acajou
de noyer ou d'érable massif alors là je
j'ajuste en fait la table donc ce sera
la partie visible de la guitare ça sera
là dessus donc j'ai un gabarit où je
vais commencer à débiter en fait le
morceau de bois
mathieu devra ensuite évident et le
corps pour pouvoir y loger les micros et
toute l'électronique avant l'assemblage
entre le manche et la table de nantes à
la guitare sa forme finale
un travail fastidieux pour ce luthier
autodidacte parti d'un simple diplôme en
menuiserie l'éditeur ça représente quand
même une centaine d'heures donc c'est
vraiment une centaine d'heures qu'on va
passer sur la même pièce on va finir par
connaître par coeur dès le début donc
oui il faut être motivé
il faut être tout le temps tout le temps
très précis et très minutieux
on a un morceau de bois qui est unique
donc on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'instrument est achevée en trois
semaines ticket d'entrée 2000 euros le
prix à payer pour s'offrir une guitare
de haute couture
c'est un modèle que j'ai essayé de
dessiner vraiment pour le musicien que
j'ai dessiné avec des musiciens pour
qu'il soit vraiment le plus ergonomique
possible et le plus jouable on arrive à
avoir des pièces qu'on n'a pas chez
certains j'ai certaines grandes marques
et a vraiment le choix des bois la
sélection la sélection des pièces une
personne une guitare de lüthi ça se
ressent notamment par exemple au niveau
des finitions
on a définition qu'on va plutôt à les
appliquer à la main pour vraiment sentir
l'instrument et on a touché vraiment
chaleureux
mathieu a lancé son activité en janvier
de cette année avant de pouvoir en vivre
décemment
une partie de la partition reste à
écrire mais le plus important est déjà
là le talent
[Musique]
maintenant cela suffit pas il faut
monter l'entreprise nous disait tout à
l'heure qu'il faut avoir un âge minimum
de 18 ans sébastien morel escale inverse
et un âge maximum pour bénéficier des
microcrédit de l'adie et de l'aide
absolument pas aujourd'hui on n'est pas
l'apanage maximum qui va une limite au
niveau de la 10e au monde
à partir du moment où la personne n'a
envie d'entreprendre quelques sa
situation son âge son genre sa
domiciliation sa situation
professionnelle
nous on est présent à d'obligations en
plus de diplômes a pas d'obligation
diplôme si on prend sur la bourgogne
franche comté l'an dernier 50% des gens
film qu'on a financé c'était des
personnes qui avaient cessé de leurs
études à la fin de la troisième par
exemple elle est super l'a dit c'est
marca là dessus un regard d une
association qui aide les personnes
n'ayant pas accès au crédit bancaire à
monter leur entreprise